Theo Vietnam Vô Sting sẫn hồn từ Financial Times,
tổng thống nghĩ đồn trò em trà lời phòng bán châu biết,
ông ông tích quản, ông tán quyền dông mỏ của yên phàn,
tự dự vơi cách tận mà Washington từng áp dụ, đối với vình như ra là.
Người đứng đường nhà trắng thẳng thẳng thẳng chiếc sạy,
điều tối mong muốn nhất là dành lấy dông mỏ tại Iran,
tuy nhiên một dúng người đối lập tại Mỹ lại chấp bấm,
tại sao lại làm thế hậu đứng gặp cả chẳng biết gì?
Đáng chung ý, tổng thống đồ nơi trắng cũng thống hội trường khả năng,
Mỹ sẽ tìm cách đánh chiếm đảo thang,
chung tâm xuống phổ và lên trường lực với văn,
nhưng phà biểu này đứng đưa ra trong thời niệm xúc đổi giữa các bên linh quan tích được lau thang,
kéo theo nhiều hệ luy, đối với ăn ninh hàng 2 tại khu vực yêu biển hòm ốt,
tối n番 chuyển năng lượng quan trọng trên thế giới.
Dù vậy, tổng thống Mỹ khẩn định tất qua đằng phán vị Iran
bản đăng tự tiến hàng thông qua cả kinh trực tiến và giám tiếp,
Phía Iran chưa được gia phản huy chính thức, đối với các tuyên bố mời nhất,
giữa qua rất trường rằng các phép biểu của lãnh động Mỹ và nánh sự kết thật,
giữa ăn lực và đối thoại trong buộc cảnh tính trình hòa ra vãnh còn nhiều yếu tổ chơi chất chắn.